welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in ahead of his return to the octagon
former ufc middleweight champion luke
rockhold spoke with the media at the ufc
278 pre-fight press conference rockhold
took his time to air out some of the
grievances he has with the ufc most
notably the issue of fighter pay one of
rockhold's key points is that while the
sport and organization has grown the
compensation for fighters has remained
stagnant rockhold proclaimed he's not
afraid of any backlash he might get from
the ufc and that he is going to use the
leverage he worked hard to build video
courtesy of mma junkie
the the company is growing and they're
implementing other little stupid ass
bonuses
five thousand dollars here five thousand
dollars there fifty thousand dollars man
we've been stuck on this
for [ __ ]
20 years i mean back when gsp fought
jake what is a hundred thousand
[ __ ] there was growing there was
there when lorenzo and frank were
running the show there was real
grounding wires these guys don't they
don't know what they're doing they're
letting dana just run the show and
suppress the sport
this they need to grow this whole thing
needs to grow together our lives are on
the line healthcare needs to be taken
care of our
health needs to be taken care of
mine is not has not been taken care of
you know what i mean it's like there's a
lot of people that there's a lot of
things need to change it's like i'm just
not gonna be scared to say it everyone
wants to [ __ ] because they want to
get that title shot they want to move up
and they i've [ __ ] done it all
and then it's like yeah this is business
every business is like this it's about
leverage it's a game of leverage and
life
and it's about
and always keeping the upper hand it's
it's not just here it's everywhere and
if you let these people think that they
have that leverage it's only going to
grow above you
so it's just people understanding their
worth
heavyweight champion francis naganu was
watching the press conference and sent
out several tweets expressing his own
thoughts on the matter listening to
luke's interview was very pertinent a
lot of things that nobody is talking
about and the company just rolls with it
fighters are ripped off with sponsorship
it's a huge source of revenue for us but
the company keeps exploiting that for
their own benefit i understand that the
sport needs to look good with uniforms
but we should at least have a right for
a minimum of two approved sponsors for
in the octagon last year i lost a deal
of over a million dollars from a crypto
exchange because the partner with
crypto.com what do i get from it
inflation is up
earlier this week on his youtube channel
middleweight champ israel otasania gave
the keys to victory for both luke
rockhold and paulo costa ahead of their
clash at ufc 278. i'd say luke should
take him down yeah luke start wrestling
straight away costa though early on
dangerous right yeah and also his hips
like i remember when you well same thing
you're trying to take them down you're
trying to they all go to the same class
or something
you're all trying to take down costa and
costa had the overhook or whatever yeah
overhook and then just wizard him and
they go back up and smile at each other
but luke if he can get some knowledge or
even just wrestling get him tired get
wear those muscles you know like wear
them out i say yeah luke trying to
wrestle him straight away do what i did
keep his legs established around leg
kicks a little bit well stop wrestling
straight away and make him tired make
him second guess
make him think know that oh he can be
taken down or there's a threat of being
taken down
hosta i think just do what he does just
barrage him yeah yeah yeah yeah and clip
him right yeah
if he clips him he's probably gonna drop
luke bkfc 27 is live from london this
saturday at 11 a.m the main event will
feature mike perry and michael venom
page the two faced off thursday for the
final time before meeting each other in
the ring during the face-off perry had
some fun at page by mimicking his
signature move
[Music]
join brendan shaw burt kreischer matt
mitrione and the rest of the thick boy
gang this saturday at 11am for the bkfc
calabasas fight companion
i'm the one and only mvp michael venom
page
entertaining unusual unique i like to do
stuff that doesn't necessarily make
sense
[Applause]
i think i'm one of the toughest men on
the planet it may not always be pretty
but damn it you can't beat me we'll see
if he ever comes forward at all
i want to go in there i want to land
shots and not be touched i'm more a
sniper like i said man if he's there at
the end of it well he'll be bleeding
connor
the drum town bombing
go
hitman
[Music]
took the time during his ufc 278
pre-fight press conference to refute
claims that his newfound stardom is
taking his focus away from fighting last
month it was announced that usman would
have a role in marvel's upcoming black
panther 2. that in addition to his
increased presence on social media and
live events has led to reports that he
has one foot out of fighting however
usman warned his opponent leon edwards
not to buy into those storylines i was
in a movie and everyone says he
hollywood now when i was in college
eating five dollar little caesars pizza
and i was surviving off that for two
days and eating ramen noodles for a
whole week you know what i did i dreamt
of getting to a point where i didn't
have to do that to where i could go into
any steakhouse wherever i wanted and
tell my mom and dad you guys want to go
there i got you let's go there you want
to fly private i got you i always dreamt
of that and always wanted that so i put
the work in to get to that point to get
to the point where i wanted silk shirts
i always wanted that i put in the work
and i got that but that doesn't stop me
i want to be bigger than dwayne johnson
i'm not bigger than him so that means i
need more work so this notion of people
who say you're hollywood now it's going
to his head if he's thinking that it's
the biggest misconception it'll be a
short night for him come saturday night
one championship makes its north
american streaming debut next week on
one on prime video one streaming giant
amazon prime video will exclusively
carry the card headlined with a title
bout between adriano marias and
demetrius johnson mariah spoke with one
and explained the opportunity he sees in
the north american market i'm a very
disciplined mma and jujitsu athlete and
that's why i believe i can be the new
face of mma in the united states i am
always waiting for new opportunities and
i will always ask god to show me the way
if that's his will i'll take it for sure
[Music]
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shop
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
you